module 3 is going to be about
all the linear algebra ideas
that will
allow us to understand singular validity
composition.
And then from their PCA.
I've seen in several books where they
say SVD is like the jewel.
Of linear algebra, they actually use that word.
And Gilbert Strang, you know famous Professor at
MIT set SVD is one of the one
of the high points or the highest point of linear algebra.
and it is a
the SVD that really requires us to
know.
I won't say the entirety of linear algebra, but a
lot of linear algebra. So in order for us to
extract the sink these things we call the singular
values from Matrix.
We need to know.
Well everything we've covered up this point everything will cover today.
and
Our next session on Wednesday. I think we can get into SVD
by Wednesday.
And PC with that's applications on
Friday.
But yeah, so we want to see the
prerequisites of
SVD
in this session. So today which is
the 11th of July.
You want to start with the following?
let me pull out that slide from
our very first session
so this module is about
this
working our way up to PC and
from there looking at its application this we will do.
in module 4
this we will do on Friday.
And this way I guess because this could be we can look at
this.
okay, so this will borrow this will be
based on systems of
linear equations, but this one for sure.
Is an application of PCA?
For this we would need some background on neural networks. But you know
now that we've covered a lot of Matrix operations. We
really we will prepare for neural networks.
So we are going to do pattern recognition using your Networks.
Okay. So today we're going to talk about the determinant
function.
First for a 2 by 2 Matrix and then by for
three by three Matrix and then we're going to talk about eigenvalues and
eigenvectors.
How we go about calculating these?
If time allows it, I also want to talk about the inversion
of a matrix.
Because that will also later be used.
and then
Again, if we can get past Target values academic actors fast enough,
we can always talk about the characters polynomial so that on
Wednesday we talk about SVD.
And it's and PC just a special case of
SVD.
So understanding this we're only a few steps away from PC.
Although we have talked about something called normalization.
but
that's not a big deal. It's it's something trivial. We will you know,
we can manage.
Okay, so we will start first with the determinant of a
matrix deter.
minant of a matrix
then we will look at eigen Computing the eigen.
vectors
And I can values.
and then characteristic
polynomial
and then if time allows it in version of a matrix.
Okay.
This will be tutorial number but 12.
as we
so the determinant of a matrix
preliminaries
or
SVD
Time is type. That word.
There we go.
Other correction has really
messed up my spelling.
capabilities
Thank you zoom out here.
Okay, so first we'll begin with determinant.
The permanent this should be
your camera determinant.
A matrix now, of course, we can only calculate determinant office
of matrices that are square.
So consider the following example, this is very straightforward and we have
a matrix.
Let's say let me just click copy paste the code to save
time from typing.
All right. So let's say we have a square Matrix.
But I'm just going to substitute the values here with the
letters a because the numbers are important. It's the operation that's important.
So this will be
a
sub 1 1
so first row First Column
This would be second row First Column third row First
Column.
And that's actually begin with the two by
two.
So I'm just going to keep this two by two.
first row second column
second row second column
the determinant of a matrix
Is denoted by Det?
and
to compute the
determinant of a
square Matrix is to
Took the product.
of the components across
the diagonal
this is only true for the square major for two by two. I'll show you how it's not
worth 2 by 3.
Take the product of a a sub 1
1 and a sub 2 2 so across this diagonal.
Then take the product.
Of the opposite diagonal or the opposite direction and then
sum them.
so determinant of a two by two Matrix is
And so the first component well, I mean you can
see here. So these two plus
these two
let's put these in parentheses for clarity.
Okay, and it will become.
like so
second row
A11 a this is incorrect. This is
a11 a22
a12
And a two one.
There we go.
That's the determinant for a
hold on a second. I did I stop.
It's a difference different. I think one of you left to
come with.
Oh, hi there. We do. It's the difference. Not the
sum.
That's the difference.
All right, three by three or yeah for
a three by three or larger.
Let me
let me let me show you how it's done.
I'm going to this so this is for us. This is for our two by two four.
2 by 2 Matrix
for three by three
we kind of have the argument as Matrix.
Something like this, so I'm going to copy this bit again.
Okay, so let's add one more Row one more column.
So this would become.
a13
This would become a two three.
and
We have one more row, so.
First Column of the third row
second column of the third row third column of the
third rule.
now
to calculate this
maybe augment this let me copy paste the same
Matrix. So becomes e visually easier to
See, I'm gonna copy that bit.
And I'm going to copy it once more.
And let me actually put them next to each other.
Okay, let's put some line break.
in order to calculate the determinant of
the three by three
we're going to multiply.
again
everything across the diagonal so this times this
times this
so the third column of the third row.
But then we also have to multiply these components.
And those components so on the upper drawing of the lower triangle. How
do we do this?
Well, the reason I augmented this Matrix is because we want to
multiply three components three components three components. So
after Computing the elements
across the main diagonal then we're going
to multiply a12.
times a two three
and then a three one.
So this element?
I'll come all the way up here.
Maybe let me also just show you this from
a different angle. So I'm going to type in determinant.
of a three by three Matrix
Okay.
So some of them use these arrows which I think
are helpful.
Let's use yeah, here we go.
So this is this this is a three by three which has been
argumented.
Okay.
So we multiply the products across the main diagonal.
And then we have B sub 1 C sub 2.
Which we wanted me to multiply with a sub three. So we're
going to copy a sub three all the way here. I mean that's all point of
mirroring.
Or reflecting if you want this Matrix so
we can have this.
business this diagonal business
And then once we've done it from there, once we've done the
cross the main dial will go the other direction. So see sub 1
B sub 2 a sub 3
and then a sub 1 is up to so
basically the exactly what I just said.
Okay.
These elements these elements and these elements. So you
see when we when we copy The Matrix now in
the examples, I showed you an example you will see they will
leave the spit out.
But I think it's just more clear if I make a duplicate.
Okay, so if I copy
this part
the determinant of a three by three would be
a11822833
a33
right, a11822833
and
that will be minus.
A12 a23 and then a three one.
So you want to
a21
or 823
and then a three one.
I'm gonna go and type this this will take forever.
But hopefully now you get the idea.
Okay.
So let's look at an example.
Just the two by two.
And then we'll move on to the next topic.
So let's say
we have
the square Matrix. I'm going to copy paste.
code
and let's say we have
You know, whatever this will be for.
This will be three.
This will be eight.
And let's make this two.
so two times three minus 8 times 2
So we have two.
times three
minus
times 2
and what will this evaluate to there? So that will be six minus 16.
so negative 10
That's the determinant of this Matrix.
Now we leave this here and come back to it.
To well, of course for every concept that
we see here. We want to know what's what's
A practically example of using the determined. So let's keep this year
so we can refer to later on.
Okay, this was determinate.
now the next topic is
eigenvectors eigenvalues
This is going to be this is going to take a couple of
minutes.
So that I can show you the whole process of.
calculating the eigenvalues
of a particular Square Matrix, and
we will we will need to
We will need to know the determinant is and we just
have found out what determinators so you can now move on and talk about.
calculating the
Eigenvalue, so let me create another file.
And call this eigen.
I'll use that.
Okay, so let me show you.
calculation of an eigen
the eigenvalues
if I type it it will be clear but more time consuming if I do
it by hand, it will be faster, but
let's clear.
Let me do it. Let me do it by hand because it would
be faster. Ross's example should be four.
example two
where
are you referring to this page?
this file
Oh, yes. Why did I get this wrong? It's
supposed to yes, it's four times three.
This is what happens when you copy paste code. So this is
a
four times three. Thank you.
Four times three, that's 12 minus 16.
And it is correctly of course times 3 is 12.
Minus 16 is negative 4. Yes. Thank you very much.
Okay.
Hope I didn't mess up any of these numbers.
Okay, eigenvalues now.
let me let me pull up my iPad because I
think it will be faster because
quite some steps involved here.
so
maybe visit a dashboard
pick number
almost there.
and then
go to the dashboard.
And click on the zoom link. Here we go.
All right.
change
waiting for Zoom to respond.
Just give me a second. Let me also get the pen.
Okay, here we go. Sorry for keeping you waiting.
Sure.
No, the iPad doesn't connect.
every single time
something has to happen.
and a few minutes has to be
we used it to these things one more time.
that the user in
and then just change this host.
Here we go.
finally share
screen
Here we go.
Okay.
you know there is a cable for this but
For some reason when I plug in the cable, it doesn't work.
It keeps on disconnecting so I have to resort to using Zoom.
Oh one second. Let me see what I just.
Okay, here we go, finally.
So let's say we have a simple 2 by
2 Matrix.
If you remember we talked about this form.
of a matrix
a x equals B
where AZ Matrix X is equal to a
vector and B is a vectors if we multiply the matrix
by the vector will get the B Vector now, this is also related to
the inverse of a matrix which will come
back to momentarily Okay, so
Let's say we have this Matrix.
Square Matrix with components 7
3 and negative 1
and we want to calculate the eigenvector for
the square Matrix
so, this is our Matrix a
Well, we all do that. Well, we will next do then is we will take this Matrix in
multiplied by the identity Matrix so we will go.
Or rather what we're going to do is we're going to take an identity
Matrix and multiply it by the scalar
Lambda.
So let's keep this as they
give it.
Okay.
And then we have the idea in The Matrix, which we know is one.
zero zero one
it will then multiply this by Lambda.
if you remember from
the X the axioms of
vectors
we can multiply scalar by effect. We can also multiply scalars.
By what the Matrix and simply
what this will do is we will substitute the ones with the
lambdas.
So this will be a variation of the identity. Matrix
will have Lambda across the diagonal.
0 elsewhere
Okay.
with this
combination
we're going to subtract.
from the
original Matrix a
this Matrix that we have created and we will represent this Matrix as a
as a Lambda times.
I
since I is used to represent the
identity Matrix we're going to represent this Matrix as
Lambda times I
so
next thing we are going to do.
is subtract from The Matrix a
Lambda
times I
in other words the difference of this Matrix.
and
the given Matrix
Okay.
This is that Matrix.
and this product
is that Matrix?
Okay.
The next thing we are going to do.
Is what the subtract these two is to do
the following.
We're going to get a third Matrix.
We have seven. Let me zoom in.
We have seven minus Lambda.
minus 1
minus Lambda
and then of course the other numbers which are three and
three
Okay.
and this
we will pass as argument to determine
it function.
So we will take this Matrix.
And then we will take the determinant of this Matrix.
And we've already seen how we can take the determinant
of a matrix it will be.
The product of these two numbers minus the
product of these two numbers.
and then we will get
maybe just copy these.
down here
So what do we get?
We get these two.
minus
3 by 3
now
if we multiply these numbers together.
We get the following.
expression
so this is the determinant of the above Matrix we
will get
minus 7
and then minus
6 times Lambda
plus Lambda squared
plus or rather minus 9
Okay, and then we solve we are.
You know do some algebra.
So adding the
minus seven to minus 9 we get
Negative 16, but we also have to make sure.
To bring the terms.
What?
The high order terms to the front. So Lambda squared must
come here to the front.
And we have minus six Lambda.
And then we get minus 16.
Now here we have.
an unknown variable
that's the eigenvalue. So we
need to find you have to solve for Lambda here.
Of course, we will Factor these two numbers.
to get
let me make some steps here. So this is
let's call this step one.
step one
subtracting
the subtracting a from Lambda times
I
so
subtract
the Matrix a from
then the times I
then we have step two.
step two
solve for Lambda
so I'm going to copy this.
expression
We can.
Factor these terms so we will get
Lambda
Lambda minus 8
and Lambda plus 2
of course is equal to zero.
And then so we will get that way
what we will have two equations not the minus 8
Lambda plus 2 if we move them to the other side of the equation this would become
Lambda equals 8.
Lambda equals to so these are our two eigenvalues.
Plant asks, do you have to take the determinant?
first and step 2
We took the determinant of your step 1.
Okay, that's a
good point. So let's make this step 3.
Let's make this step three two, excuse
me from my
Handwriting this is why why you use latex to avoid?
So having to correct myself continuously step two
would be yeah step two would be
the determinant.
Step 2
would be
determinant of that
question
just bring this down here.
So determinant of
That right.
so
by the way, I will write this all down in latex. So you
don't have to look at this. It's just faster to go to for
me to have to do this by running.
Now we can do is we can go back to the Lambda times
I Matrix so this one up here.
and plug in
the roots so we can either use eight or
two
So here's what we will do next.
Actually, I meant to say this Matrix this one this one.
We're going to plug in the values for Lambda.
Okay, as a matter of fact, let me copy this. I'm
just going to copy this thing.
So we step four.
Let's bring this down here.
here
I have to drag it all the way down here. Just
there we go.
So first step four we have these two roots.
We can use either one of them. Let's do.
Let's do it first.
Although the solution book for well, we'll work for either one. Both of
those will give you your eigenvector.
so the step four
plug-in values
or
Lambda
in the determinant of the
function so in
okay, this will give us a matrix. We're going to take one
of those roots and plug it into this Matrix.
Well, no the determinant of a matrix doesn't give us a matrix it
give us a it gives us a determinant which
is a scalar value.
What I should have done is remove the determines.
Yes be very careful with what I say.
So
let's just bring this over here.
now the determinant the difference
of a
and
Lambda terms are times. I
that's this Matrix. This is that Matrix.
So we will take one of those numbers.
8 and plug in for these values
So we're gonna I'm gonna copy this.
And to replace the lambdas with 8.
with 8
and then we simplify this. Yes, so we have negative 1
we have negative 1 we have three.
three
this is three and this is negative 9.
so
At what do we do next we?
we represent this as a
system of equations
so we can find x sub 1 and x sub 2
where x sub 1 and x sub 2 are the values in
the eigenvector.
So step 5.
Now that we found the eigenvalues we can solve or we
can find the eigenvector.
find
the
eigenvectors
eigenvector
single we have the argument values
we can now find the eigenvector.
So to do this we are going to create an
augmented Matrix. So I'm going to take this Matrix.
Don't take this.
Copy it.
down here
and we are going to have a square Matrix. Excuse
me. We're gonna have a vector.
essentially what this?
Equation represents is the following.
we have
we want to solve we want to find the eigenvector. So
basically
the vector
That when we multiply by this Matrix.
gives us
that vector
and so the values of this Vector are unknown and
we will say x sub 1 and x sub 2
x sub 1 x sub 2
so we have minus 1 x sub
Plus
3 x sub 2
equals 0
and we have in the second equation 3.
x sub 1 plus negative 9 x
up to equal 0
and like we saw in the linear program example, we need
to solve.
these equations or at least
as you know
eliminally one of them
Eliminate one of them. Let me show you what elimination means
so I'm going to once again.
We're going to augment the above Matrix.
If you remember what we said about augmenting matrices, so let
me just copy you not gonna be copy the whole thing.
I'm gonna copy the whole thing.
It's down here.
When you augment a matrix.
What you do is you you bring these two matrices together and then you separate
them by some vertical line.
This vertical line means there's an equation.
So everything to the right side is an equation everything the
left side are well.
the variables
these are your variables.
and these are the
the zeros of your equation
What we will then do is use.
Get the gaussian elimination to find the
X's.
so
I'm going to for the time being remove
this.
Augmented the augmented part because they're
all equal to zero.
and
but this looks like it's
Parallel, isn't it?
because if you
Multiply the first one by a negative number you're going to get 1 minus
3 which is and multiplied by 3. You're going to get the same
as the button.
So X1 and X2 is going to be 0.
So I don't think I understood repeat your question, please.
up here
or you think they won't be long, right?
You multiply the first one by negative 3 then
you're gonna get 3x1.
Minus 9 x 2 equals 0 which is the same as the bottom
one.
Yeah, so basically we want to eliminate this
rule so we will exactly what you said
So in order for us to eliminate this
row.
because once we eliminate the first row the second row
then we have found then we can solve for
at least just for just one equation. So to do
this we're going to
take
Row one multiplied by three just like you said,
so three times R1
and add that to
Row 2
and the result of this we will override or we will
put inside or two.
Okay. So what we
are doing is this
this operation
multiply
3 times negative 1 so multiply 3
3 will apply to all the terms.
and this equation
so and we actually remove the augmented Matrix so
we don't need to worry about this anymore.
This will become negative 3.
negative 3
this will become positive 9.
Add these two.
Well, I can't call them equations anymore. Let me bring back to 0 so their equations
now, they're equations if we add these terms together.
What do we get we get well.
Well, everything becomes a zero.
So the result of this.
Edition
this will become this will become the second row.
the second row
in other words after we perform this calcium
this what we're very simple gaussian
step.
calculate elimination step
this Matrix
will become
that Matrix
these becomes zeros.
Now we can plug in these values into the equation.
So remember we have x sub 1
and x sub 2
and we want to know what these are.
So to do that.
We're going to say negative 1.
X Plus
3 x squared
and these are the values now.
These are the values of x sub 1 x of it because if we
multiply this Matrix will put that vector.
We will get these numbers.
So these are now the components of the eigenvector. So now
the eigenvector is
well, it's it's the it's here minus one and three.
So if you go all the way back up.
if we go all the way back up to
The Matrix up here
Where did I put it?
Yeah this one.
So if you want to find the b
or we're going to do is we're going to multiply the matrix
by the eigenvector that we just found.
And you will find what B is so.
I'm going to copy this.
But I don't want to go all the way down. So I'm just going to
copy it up here.
so this is a
X we just found that was equal to
negative 1 and 3, correct?
on my notes, it says 1
What did I do wrong again?
So
I missed a step here.
and
alright
I need to move the
yeah, I need to solve for the I need to solve for these.
That's this is incorrect. So before I can do that.
I need to set this to zero and then solve for x sub
1.
And x sub 2 so minus
one X will become.
or rather what I can do is I can
swap these I can have three x sub
and then subtract
minus
1X to bring this to the
other side
So we will have One X.
And we just to simplified the notation. That's
just and sorry. This will be positive One X.
positive 1X
and if we just lose the one because we don't
put the constant there when it's 1 then X is
just equal to
X is just equal to 3 times x
sub 2
That's except one.
and
well x sub 2
so here we have.
our vector
x sub 1 is equal to 3.
Right if we swap the orders.
we'll get three X2 and if
we solve for x sub 2
then
we'll have x sub 2 equals.
except
And lose the three.
What do we do?
Yeah, we just divide both sides by 3.
So this will become one.
Anyway, this is this is the this is the correct eigenvector.
Come back up here.
We will have three.
so x sub 1
x sub 2
now, of course we need to
Do the Matrix times do the vector
Matrix Vector multiplication in one
sense? Rhs right hand side is zero. We can
always divide by 3 and get back to the original.
Yes now to so this
is now a we have found the eigen we have
found the components for the eigenvector.
now
To be now. We need to multiply this so we will multiply these and
we will get
maybe do this very quickly.
So this will be seven.
Times three and three times one anyway, skipping
skipping the most the
product and some business. We will get this.
third vector
which is equal to 24.
and date
And what's interesting is that we can Factor.
The scalar eight from this Matrix. So this is now B.
So another way to represent this vector.
is to represent it like so
is to go 8 the scalar multiplied by
times 1
and it turns out this is one of the this was one of the values for
the eigenvalue.
So if you multiply this 8 by 3, we will get 24.
multiply 8 times 1 obviously will get 8
All right.
This is how you calculate.
The eigenvalues and I how you find
argument that is not eigenvector 402 by 2.
very
I don't want to say tedious but you know, you have
to first do the difference find the difference.
of the
identity Matrix that is multiplied by Lambda.
Then you will get a third Matrix.
So then you have to take the determinant of that Matrix.
Once you take the term of that Matrix you will that's you will
get this.
expression
and then you have to solve for laptop and you will get two values
two eigenvalues.
So run ask what are eigenvectors good for?
They are a way to encode.
values in square matrices
So in statistics, we have something called.
variance
From which we can get standard deviation?
Then there's a matrix called The Core variance Matrix.
From which we can get the correlation Matrix and the correlation Matrix.
will encode the correlation of multiple factors, for
example
Let's say you want to see.
What?
factors influence the
salary a person gets
let me actually pull up a picture from Google Images.
I'm gonna have to stop sharing.
Let me stop sharing.
Make myself host here.
And share the screen.
Okay.
correlation
Matrix
Let's see what they have written here on the sides even Capital. It's
something something more.
basic
Okay, these are not as correlated as much something that is hiding.
I want to basic example, so you get the point.
Yeah, this could work I suppose.
This is a correlation Matrix.
so eigenvectors alone
may they're not.
Maybe they don't have
interesting applications, but they will
get us to something like
SVD or PCA
Let me first show you the correlation Matrix, okay?
Now, of course the Matrix here, this is colored.
But the actual correlation Matrix that you look at.
is
Just a matrix of numbers.
Now, why do we see this full red color in here that
because that's because and by the way, this is this has to do
with data relating to different cars MPG
stands for miles per gallon miles per
gallon the number of cylinders displacement.
I remember what that refers to but the horsepower of the car the weight
of the car.
And the acceleration the car correlation in statistics
is a number that goes from negative 1 to positive one where
positive one is a very strong positive
correlation negative 1 is a strong inverse correlation.
So as the more of this you have
the less of the other you have.
And the correlation of zero or something that is close to zero means that these
two these two things are not.
really correlated
So, of course if we start here at the top component of
this Matrix now you're trying to imagine this is an actual Matrix.
Okay.
Miles per gallon of miles per gallon obviously since the
same.
Feature or same factor, they will have 100% correlation.
But but then we can compare miles per gallon.
and the cylinders
you can see the cylinders are negatively strongly correlated
with Mossberg than I see strongly because it's almost 0.8.
It is also negatively.
And strongly correlated with displacement and horsepower and
wait.
Let's solid acceleration.
So basically this Matrix is some sort of.
Contains information. It's some sort of encoding.
You can use this to look up to very quickly
establish the like I said the strength of
correlation.
Now, let me if I let me see if I if I can
type in.
I have a I have an example from a book PCA.
correlation
Matrix
and stock prices
again
We think they predicting stock prices not something you can actually do.
Okay, but again, I'll use that
an example.
And the reason I say stock prices again, I'm not an
investor but every book.
I've come across is that you really can't predict stock prices?
And if you're investor you're but your best artist to invest
in indices.
Which is like a mixed bag of stocks anyway.
Never mind, whether stock prices are something
you can predict or not. Let me just show you.
A practical application not of eigenvectors.
but
SVD
And PCA which require the calculation of
eigenvectors.
I don't think I'll be able to find it here or is this
the one?
Let me show you PCA. Let me show you PCA PCA and
dimensionality reduction.
so
this could work.
Let's open this keep this here.
and
Maybe this one as well. Let me try another one.
3D
you
don't even
Yes, my understanding of eigenvectors. Basically.
It's a linear transformation of
a vector into an orthogonal space that is
easier to understand and work with so so even
with PCA what like PCA component
one and PCA component two orthogonal to
each other so when you know in which
direction
or the
The relationship of the data how it's moving.
Yeah, but we haven't talked about orthogonal matrices. So I'm just trying to look for some visual.
That's very.
I think this isn't good enough.
Okay, so let me open this here. Let's use this.
Yeah, we haven't covered all the types of matrices so which is why I said, you know
like I dedicated entire module for PCA.
And let me also type in correlation here.
Just correlation.
Okay, just a little bit of Statistics here correlation.
Is something you can both compute?
with
basic arithmetic
and it is something that is very visually simple to
See, for example, let's look at this picture over here.
Okay.
Again, this is a these are
Green Dots. We call observations. So for example
and
again, let's consider two factors. The x-axis is
a
The years of education you have and the
y-axis is your salary.
Let's just let's just say hypothetically these two things are
very strongly correlated. In fact, they have 100% correlation.
So salary is
Purely a function of how much?
How many years you've spent in college not the case and really the real world but
let's say no hypothetical World which is why we get this.
Which is why you know every observation here.
false
on this vertical line
And so even if we want to remove this line, you
could see a clear pattern.
More salary, excuse me, more experience most more education
more salary.
Then here we have inverse relationship. So the more of something you have
the less of the the other for example.
X-axis could be the number of hours you spend on social
media.
And why access could be?
your level of happiness
I think we can all agree that is true to some extent right? So the
more time you spent on social media.
The less happy you become.
I know that is true for me. I
use social media for news
and nothing could ever comes out of it, but I still do it
anyway, but these two factors are negatively correlated.
I get but again it consists call it because you have this pattern now
in reality. You will never get this perfectly. You will
never have all of these observations for nicely on
this straight line. They will be somewhere around it.
And then but these are extreme examples just to make a point.
And of course we have something that's on code when something on color
you don't there is no clear pattern.
Like is it going up? Is it going down everything is scattered around?
Okay, and we say this you have a lot of residuals. So residuals are
the distance between observations from this line.
So this on correctly.
Now this is a two-dimensional.
data point or two dimensional
comparison. We're comparing two factors.
In reality, you're going to have a lot of features consider
this example where we have three features.
Right, so we have three axes and maybe you
can see a pattern. Maybe you can see a plane.
go from like this point and then just
goes higher up
But there are situations where we
have.
For the for the for the four features or four
factors in statistics. We say factors and Machinery
we say features.
We will use this word in module 4 but let's say you have
four dimensions five Dimensions 10 Dimensions. So 10 factors.
and
you do not know.
the
validity of the correlation
Let me Give an example, let's say we are talking about shoe sizes
Imagine you have a data set.
Let me come to vs code.
And our data set is a CSV file.
A CSF or imagine an Excel sheet with the following
columns.
Okay. I'm going to come back to PC and I get vectors.
In a second, so we have what are
the shoes that what are different ways shoe sizes are labeled.
There's the US shoe size.
There is the UK shoe size. There's a European shoe
size.
There is the Japanese shoe size.
And then there's centimeter.
Okay, which is the most precise?
form of measuring
Now, of course all four of all five factors, here are strongly
correlated the if you have a large shoe
size.
in the US column
or you will have a larger shoe size the UK column. I mean
that's obvious, right?
If you have a bigger if you if you have a larger shoe size,
it will be larger across the board.
Okay, and this is quite this is
common sense. We don't need anything special but what if
we come across the data set that looks like this.
And these will be very strongly correlated. So this will be
one one.
Okay.
But let's consider an example where something is
not very clear. You will come across data sets with
the car that features are not meaningful.
now, let's say we have
I don't know. I'm not a biologist, but let's say different.
protein so we have P sub 1
piece up to
piece of 3
p sub 4
Okay.
different types of proteins
What are they be there is leucine.
What are different types of the different, you know, the different
types of proteins we have?
RDL Arginine and the others okay, but even
in data said they may not be properly named.
Moreover you might not always have a domain expert you
see in situations like this.
Or this example here where we had, you know.
miles per cylinder
miles per gallon. Okay. If you
do not know what a displacement is and how it's related to
miles per gallon. You can always consult someone.
Like mechanic or an automotive engineer and
they will explain to you. Why why it's the
case that these two are.
Strongly correlated to each other but you will
not always have something like you might have something like this what it is not popularly.
And you still want to perform machine learning on this data set
now in the above example here.
How many dimensions do we have? We have five dimensions?
Okay.
This is on. This is an unnecessarily High
dimensional data.
It will make it difficult more for the machine learning model to learn
what we call the hyperparameters of our
features.
long story short if I can really simplify this PC
will allow us to
collapse the dimensions go from five Dimensions
to three dimensions to do dimensions.
So for example, we can just have and you
know what let's add a sixth column here. And let's call this height, right? It
is the case that taller people.
have
larger shoe sizes
and let's say it's a very strongly correlated.
Okay, 95% correlation.
We can reduce the dimensionality so we can go from these six columns
to two columns what you will call.
pc1 and PC2 principle component
1 and principle component two
Again, this is the stuff. I left for the Friday session.
But it allow us to collapse our data and
only retain relevant information.
This is especially you know, in in this data set
we could have just stuck with one of these units of right we could have just used
one of these sizes because you know, what forget about the Internationals
the other shoe size. This is you sent a meter.
This is the most accurate.
measurement
and we don't need to do anything complicated but in
a situation like this we do.
We we do not know how they are correlated and to what
extent.
And we do not want to keep five dimensions.
Because it could be more than five. It could be 20 Dimensions 50 Dimensions. It
is not something we can.
manage
or want to manage at least
so what we will do is we will use the technique of PCA to
collapse this I will use that would collapse to
get PC one PC.
PC2
so this is what we mean by dimensionality reduction.
pc1 will encode pc1 and
PC2 would encode
the variance
amongst these data
and another for us to calculate in order for us to perform PCA we
need well, I can calculating the eigenvalues is
one step to getting that point. But
again, these are the steps you have to perform completely.
The calculate the eigenvalues you need to determine it to calculate the calculator.
Now we need eigen eigenvalues to
calculate again everything.
All the layers below all the subsequent layers below
are prerequisite. So this
has prerequisite that this intern has
prerequisite that this internet has prerequisite that so
what I'm trying to do is mmm cover these
prerequisite so we can jump into practical applications of SVD and
PCA.
So these alone?
I can't come up with any interesting examples.
in of applications
But these are definitely interesting.
Now maybe that's not a satisfying answer and I know it's not.
I actually look for different examples of applications of
eigenvalues.
but the olds in one way or another point to
ultimately to these to these techniques up here.
Okay. Now I'm going to clean up the note for
the the whole iPad stuff for
eigenvalues.
But I hope at least you you see what
the at least you can determine what the determin it is if I
come back here.
Pull this up.
The key thing is the determinant.
and the rest of it was just
basic algebra
and
scalar multiplication Matrix difference a differences
Okay.
Any question or comments before I move on to the next topic? Let me
check the chats. There's anyone say anything else.
okay, there's
two comments
Is a simple definition for PCA replace
data in a specific Dimension with a function?
not quite
because we're not replacing the data we are.
encoding the data
in a smaller dimension
And from our example for today, can we graph the
input of the two by two Matrix and then it's eigenvector?
How do you mean graph it?
So if I go back to the and send the iPad but this
is the original Matrix.
This is the original Matrix.
And we copy the step. It's here.
The original Matrix was this.
Seven three and three one.
but
what is the what is your what is your
motivation for wanting to visualize it
No, not necessarily this could be.
Let me this Matrix is not particularly special. That's the problem.
This Matrix. Okay, so you let me see
if I can find your practical example.
Let's see if I can show you something.
Let me Google something for
you. I can factors.
or
hmm. Let me do this PCA correlation
Matrix.
principle
components
the example for my book is quite helpful.
Not sure if I can find something online.
Let's see this example over here.
something
With a picture on it.
Yeah, this is this is something like that something like
this. Now. What is the original table?
Do they have an original table? I this has
to do with a stock prices. I'm sure.
and where is the
yeah, this tattoo has to with stock prices.
If only I could find a table. I think this is a chapter
of a book.
but let's say let's say
you
You have you have a scenario like this?
You have a portfolio of stocks.
and
if one stock price increases
the stock price
of the price of another stock also increases
so let's say for example
We have a portfolio of 100 stocks.
and
Let's and I know new one you're more
into Finance. So it give me an example of one stock
that would increase.
The stock price of well, the price of one stock they would increase with
the price of another stock.
for example now
the price of
wheat
I think is that wheat as a commodity is higher. I
want the stock price of wheat goes up.
Anything that has to do with that particular commodity was also all
feel feel like oh petroleum. Yeah,
so when the price
of controlling increases
The price of what other what other commodity
increases the price of
bread increases for the price of bread increases because the price of
shipping increases the price of shipping will have the
factored into the purchase. And so when the price of oil
goes up so does the price of bread
but then
companies will have this
this the cost of petroleum will
You know mmm.
The expense this increased expense will navigate is
exactly exactly run. I mean, I don't need to say this you hear
this all the everyday in the news. The price of crude goes up rent goes
up electricity goes up food goes
up.
buying anything from the supermarket goes up, right so
let's say
that you have now crude is pretty
clear.
But let's say you have
stock stocks or any type of
commodity who's correlation is not clear at
least not to
one
Financial analyst like it. It's gonna take more than just
a few or a handful of experts to determine
the correlation.
There are too many factors involved. There's too many things that establish the Coalition
of two stock prices.
So when you apply PCA, you
can't contain you can encode the
correlation.
inside
these vectors we call the principal components.
So what I'm trying to say is this
You can.
Reduce the dimensionality of your
data set. So again, we said we have 100 different stock
prices.
So you can collapse it into one two
or three principal components.
and
those principal components will then allow you
to make.
the appropriate investment
again
It's very difficult for me to like.
Demonstrate a PC without having covered the prerequisites. I did
see a nice picture here just a while ago.
PCA
in I think was PC in a nutshell.
so generally in like a modern portfolio Theory what
it says is
You want to invest your creative portfolio
in a way that?
You put your money or distributed in
opposingly varying.
assets or stocks
So that way one stock is going up then the other
one is going down. And if the other one is going down there, so the
one is going up. So basically the variants are
opposing. So therefore there are negatively correlated
so that way you're
Average return at the end is going to be still.
Good.
Precisely because you always making money.
You always gonna make money.
Because we have like this sea star situation.
but
yeah, so just like we want to point it out.
We want to find out.
opposing variance
and to do that we have to go through this series of calculations
to get to where we want. So this is where we want to end up.
and our starting point
at least in linear algebra is
this is missing some steps.
But the steps that we will cover.
In our next Workshop include we've already done
eigenvectors. I'm gonna clean up the note, but we did Cover eigenvalues and
eigenvectors.
and if you see here it says
Pick the eigenvectors with the highest eigenvalues.
Because those we can then use
to find out on correlated uncorrelated data.
Which we can use to optimize our portfolio.
So now we've learned how to do this.
We've learned how to extract.
eigenvalues and calculate eigenvectors from
it's from a square Matrix now, of course in
When it comes to something like a portfolio.
Optimization or what have you the square? Matrix
would be a lot larger. You'll have a large data. But as
long as Square makes you we can always calculate the eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
This is missing some stuff. So I'm not gonna use this many longer for reference.
but
yeah, I think we can cover these two, you know in our
next session.
And I will give you a practical example of SVD.
So we will of course on Friday talk about PC for
these two.
But tomorrow but excuse me on Wednesday, I'll give you a practical
application of SPD, but we need to First cover this part at
least.
Okay that a normalization.
Okay, we have seven minutes left. Let me
see how we can use this time wisely.
Let me show you the code. I think I can at least
show you part of the characteristic polynomial.
Here we go.
I have it here.
Rona scores the eigenvector. Yeah, so let me come here. Let me
show you.
so if this was the square Matrix
It's eigenvector turned out to be.
this
It was three. Whoops.
It was three and one.
and
this was equal to
to 24
and
When we want what do we do the when we multiply
this matrix by the vector, we'll get 24.
and 8 which we can also represent as
8 so we can Factor the scalar eight from these two
components to get.
three and one multiply 8
by 34
And it turns out that eight was the eigenvalue one
of the eigenvalues we found.
so the eigenvalue
which we represent or
the note would Lambda.
was equal to 8
and I've had we also use two if we had gone through
the whole process with number two. We would also found another eigenvector.
Okay.
so this
was a
times Lambda
make the Lambda bold because
it's an eigenvector.
equals B
characteristic polynomial
and we lost supposed to talk about the inversion of
a matrix.
I have notes for
in a version of a matrix, but even that's that's
I would have to spend a few minutes or like
10 minutes to go through those steps, but
here are the comments I have.
So we will I'm not sure if you can cover this on Wednesday.
But I think the notes.
If you go through the notes should be able to understand how
to calculate the inverse of a matrix because
we've already covered the prerequisite which is Gauss elimination.
So here
the inverse of a matrix
Is a matrix when multiplied by the
original gives you an identity Matrix?
so
Actually, there are two prerequisites gaussian
elimination.
and
if you remember from Led composition
we talked about keeping track.
of the elimination matrices well
I don't have a written down here. But it my
point is as in order to get to be so we have this a in
order to get to be what we will first to is argument.
Argument this eight maybe this two by
two for example with the identity Matrix.
And then we use gaussian elimination.
to get to
the
inverse of the Matrix which will be in the
second chord in the second half. So let me see if
I can show you what I mean. I will type here.
inverse of a matrix
Hopefully we'll get the picture that we want.
augmented
identity
Yeah, this is the one.
So we'll put the picture.
So this is the let's say this. Let's say
this is your original Matrix.
So here we have a
but let's just imagine a was actually equal to this three
by three.
this three by three
why you then do use the argumented by an identity Matrix
and we know it's identity because we have one's across the
diagonal zero elsewhere. Well we're then going to do is use Gauss
elimination like we learned in the
previous sessions.
two well eliminate all
three rows and remember to eliminate is
to have once
across the diagonal
the purpose of this augmented Matrix is to keep
track of the elimination just like we did in LED composition.
So we do these Gauss and elevation Etc. And then
eventually we'll get to this point.
This is the solution.
Or this is the this is the row reduce row
Echelon form of the original Matrix and this
Matrix to the right.
Is the the elimination of Matrix it
has we have kept track of the operations we've done.
This is now the inverse.
of
that
So this Matrix down here?
The augmented part is the inverse of
that multiply this.
and that and you will get an identity Matrix you will get
This Matrix again. You might
ask a question like yes today. What is a practical application of?
the inverse of a matrix on its own
Nothing interesting.
But it is in more.
Advanced linear algebraic techniques will this will
become in handy so for PCA
and for SVD, we need to use eigenvalue eigenvectors,
which I'll only know when they're not so interesting.
Similarly, there will be other situations where we will
need to know the identity of The Matrix.
Okay.
anyway
We've run out of time. I was hoping we would do more and we
could do an exercise, but I'm just gonna have to write these
as I'm gonna have to share this to tutorial. I'll take the
notes from the iPad turn it into a
markdown file
and maybe add my comments in here because we need
to cover these before Wednesday.
So
yes.
there won't be a video but hopefully
the writing will suffice
and then on Wednesday, we will talk about
SVD and we will look at practical applications. So
we will go back to python.
I will give you a data set and we will use SVD.
and then Friday
We will look at the example. You know that even the one gave
us portfolio optimization.
And then in module 4, like I said module 4 we will talk
about new networks. So we'll
talk about these things. We call input layers
hidden layers upper layers.
Then we will install tensorflow which will allow us
to build your networks. And then we'll see how we can use PCA for
pattern recognition
Okay.
So hopefully the next Workshop will be more.
Interesting to you, but we did have to cover these prerequisites. Okay
everybody.
Thank you so much. I will upload these notes.
As soon as possible no later than tomorrow morning.
But I'll until next time. Take care. Bye.